we're going to back up now and take a
big picture look reminding people that
the 2020 election was
in the words of president trump's own
department of homeland security quote
the most secure in american history but
ahead of that vote before the 2020
election nearly 60 percent of all
americans said that they already lacked
confidence in the honesty of american
elections here we are a year later and
two-thirds of all americans believe our
democracy is threatened that's according
to a cbs news poll and the reality is
that is a crisis of trust that is bigger
than just one party
i sat down with two very different
voters one republican one democrat to
talk about something that they share in
common
doubt in the system
what was it like in washington on
january 6th
well it's a little chilly out here but
it was freezing there as people stormed
the capitol one year ago today
sharon storey and her husband victor did
not follow the crowd inside
people started singing the national
anthem and it came all across all of us
and everybody once they started hearing
it was participating
and it was just exciting but this
grandmother of 10 who had driven all the
way from gaffney south carolina to be
there
firmly believes that the american
democracy she used to teach about in her
sixth grade classroom
is on the edge
of collapse do you think a civil war is
possible in your lifetime i think if
they push people too far against the
wall
especially the southerners
they're not going to take it and it's
not just story who worries that when it
comes to actual fighting we are closer
than any of us would like to believe
how confident are you
that the 2020 election was the most
secure in american history not at all
that's a joke no it was not
that feeling of fraud if only a feeling
is what led so many to washington on
january 6 to in their minds
defend democracy the words that come to
mind for you to describe the feeling and
the atmosphere there
what are they
patriotic unity
hope
when you hear other people describe it
as a riot or an insurrection
how do you feel
i feel upset
her belief that the election was stolen
is shared by millions
and it doesn't seem like anything or
anybody can restore their faith do you
trust congress not now
not even republicans
do you trust journalists the media even
fox news who we used to have respect for
you know seems to let us down and called
the election early do you trust the
courts
oh my what's particularly dangerous
about this moment though according to
people who have studied democratic
decline is that these feelings of
mistrust exist across party lines
albeit for very different reasons how
did you feel watching
bernie sanders lose to hillary clinton
in the primary that was when i lost a
good amount of my faith in the system
alicia sedassi is a bartender in
brooklyn who believes the will of the
voters was thwarted in 2016
by super delegates in the primary
donald john trump and the electoral
college in the general election i don't
think that any part of the election had
democracy fulfilled i mean trump didn't
get the majority of votes so
how is that democracy right while
sedasi's doubts in the system are
different from those expressed at the
capitol last year the effect is very
much the same so you don't trust
congress it's hard to trust congress
yeah you don't trust the supreme court
narrowing it down right despite their
differences both women see themselves as
defenders of the same underlying
principles you consider yourself to be a
patriot yes
are you proud to be an american yes
i think that i am a patriot because i'm
fighting for what
our constitutional rights are supposed
to be and what this country says it is
and both say they'll continue to vote
and even organize for their side i still
participate in it because
i have faith that there is the
possibility for change are you going to
trust the results
well i'll vote because i always vote but
i don't know that i'll trust them so
regardless of who wins in 2024
many voters and maybe even most could
once again doubt the results
raising the question of how our republic
can withstand such a crisis how
concerned are you about the future of
the country i'm very concerned i think
we're at a pivotal point
i think that good people can't stand by
and do nothing anymore america is as a
matter of record the longest
continuously operating democracy on the
planet
are we going to keep it
i mean all empires fall
yeah and that's a scary thought there
alicia does leave us with a note of hope
i can tell you that she is interested in
politics may even run herself both of
those women you heard from continue to
vote so they have some hope that the
system can recover
i also want to point out that we're
putting those two voters together but
there's not equivalence in the journey
to that feeling to that feeling of doubt
uh there's only one party who was
responsible for the attack on the
capitol behind me uh there's one party
primarily responsible for undermining
the faith in the 2020 results but when
you have voters on both sides
distrusting the system you you put the
country in a situation where we're going
to be wobbling into the future and i'm
not sure we're going to stay afloat as a
result it's a very dangerous
line to walk and how we get off it is a
challenge of our time
well it's been my experience tony
wobbling is never good and you know what
what struck me about that piece
is that the only thing that united those
two is how messed up the system is and
how broken the country is and that just
makes me very sad i'm still trying to
cling on to hope as we sit here one year
later yeah as different as they may be
as different as their views are they
still have some common ground on what
they agree with they both believe
they're patriots patriot is defined as
someone who vigorously supports their
country and is willing to defend it the
question is where is the truth and if we
can all land on truth together then
we'll be in a better place that's for
sure